What a lot of tribes don't realize is your husband is weird,
and people can pick up on that.
So I read an article that Hannah Neilman is super pissed about
the original article written about her,
because she's so annoyed at the backlash,
and it was, you know,
a plot against her and her family and blah, blah, blah.
And I feel like,
especially since I am kind of like the voice of the anti Chad wife,
I wanna explain why. Why that happened in the first place.
She specifically says that she feels like it was an attack against her,
her family, and her husband.
And then she has to, like,
defend that, like,
this is the life that they choose,
they co do everything, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Because just using her words,
her life, and her experience,
we can understand what the fuck is going on.
It doesn't take a fucking genius to see what's going on.
She says she rejected him for six months,
and he. And he wouldn't listen.
He said the first moment he saw her,
he was like, check.
Ready to go. Let's go.
Sign her up. Lock it in.
I'm ready to go. So she was a trophy in his eyes.
From the beginning, he was relentless.
And in pursuing her, he stopped her.
To the point of, you know,
using his connections to get next to her on a flight
to act like it's kiss Matt.
Like all them fucking Chump that text their girlfriend at 11:11
trying to act like, oh my god,
I don't even know what that's about,
you know what I mean? Like that's fucking creeper status. Okay?
It's not that they had to judge your life in any kind of way.
It was clear to see just from the.
The fucking facts that exist.
Other huge piece to this is the fact that she says, oh,
I feel old and tired. And he's telling her,
well, we wanna fill.
Fill that 15 seater.
You can hear the coercive control that goes on in the relationship.
And if you can see it on such a light level
when we're supposed to be talking about something fun
like your little farm in the cute shit you do,
but you could pick up on his ugly vibes,
that's where the concern is coming from.
It's like from the actual quote,
it's not from anything the journalist inferred.
And it's fair for the journalist to kind of put there like,
this was the vibe I was feeling,
cause a lot of communication is nonverbal.
You pick up on things. You're seeing the looks and the.
That you can feel the tension in the room.
Of course you're gonna put that in an article.
I have a whole podcast episode releasing today.
I'm editing it right now
where I go into greater detail about everything
that I find problematic with their relationship.
Based on facts, not on anything that the Journalist tried to,
you know, infer in place in there on his own.
But what I'm saying is,
you were a young girl when this man swept into your life, just,
like, barged his way in,
like, a bowl in a China shop,
convinced you with all his magical tricks
of all this magical, wonderful life you were gonna have.
And it's not exactly what you thought it was gonna be.
You thought you'd get trips to Greece.
Instead, you get an egg apron.
We can all see it. It's not the article.
It's just the life.
The podcast will be out later today. Check the channel.